there are three kinds of simple way of
looking at the first one we looked at
was done random sample I'm going to
explain what the second one is okay but
before I explain what is you have to
realize why there is a problem with just
regular safely so put your pens down
forever and look up which myself will go
about beginning a theme to this by the
way there in the real world every silver
should be designed to a problem tends to
create its own problems so we design new
solutions and just try and keep working
with things and massaging things like
it's not like some someone up on a
mountain on editing stone random samples
shall be the way it's like people just
try to solve this problem okay random
samples are really really useful but but
they don't always achieve they go now
this is why I put this in another color
I emphasize to you right equal
representation is the goal now I want
you to just jot down a few numbers with
me let's just consider our school let's
just consider our school for a minute
now a the school of 2000 students and
this is not exactly but it's close
enough for us to work with it about half
of us a boys and half of us a girl if I
wanted to select a group for example a
sample of nine students out of our mm
okay by the way is anyone know like 90s
a famous number to put one like a a
bunch of people represent you and know
why nine it's an important number
come on Legal Studies people know so so
nine that's a very very important number
in the legal world because it's the
number of people on it's the number of
Justices in the US Supreme Court okay so
it's a really big deal
it's disappointing it's a really big
deal anyhow suppose suppose I want to
pick out all of our school
I want to panel of nine right so this is
going to be my random sample now
interestingly if I do something like
this okay give every single student in
the school name number and then you know
use our grid or a calculator spreadsheet
to get numbers from one to two thousand
okay
I'm going to close a question to you and
then I just want you to have a guess as
to what you think the answer might be
okay and then I'll tell you what the
answer is to actually crunch the numbers
okay pal of mine right I love 9 clearly
it would be good to get an equal
representation of boys and girls or
pretty close to them okay now he's the
question I'm gonna pose to you and I've
asked you to tell me what the
probabilities maybe you want to write
down the question what's the probability
what's the chance of either having twice
as many boys as girls or having twice as
many girls as boys in other words the
majority is more than double than
minority whatever that happens to be
whichever way that is okay so that would
be like 6 3 or 3 6 or 7 2 + 2 7 that
kind of thing now I want you to just use
your intuition okay on a scale from zero
percent to a hundred percent that's a
good idea what do you think is the
choice then there will be a more than a
two to one or more majority because
clearly that would no longer be equal
representation right that would be
failing the intent okay so here's what I
want you to do you think I'll give you
about 15 20 seconds scale of one to a
hundred how likely as a percentage do
you think it is that this will actually
be the case just think about it for a
minute think about what the chances are
just rolling around in your
and equal numbers okay so let me ask you
this you've got I hope you've written
down some number it doesn't mean it
matter how close or how long it is okay
do you think would you say on a scale
from very unlikely to sort of unlikely
to very likely to like absolutely
certain what do you think it is on the
scale yeah pretty unlikely who agrees
with unlikely yeah
we're decent number of people okay I'm
going to tell you what the number is
because I went in crunched it it's 51%
there's a 51% chance that the boys will
be double or more than the girls or the
girls will be double or more than the
boys in other words I'll show you in a
minute you're buying in other words it's
kind of made a mockery of this equal
representation so to solve this problem
right to solve this problem
remember we're in the business of
solving problems by coming up new
solutions that you don't new problems
but that's okay
what we're trying to introduce is if you
thought like groups subgroups in your
population in your type operation draw
something like this like a rectangle
with different sort of proportions here
so if you got a bunch of subgroups in
your target population like this
if you say okay I want there to be equal
representation of all these different
kinds of subgroups within myself right
all you have to do is say well how much
of the group is this red group right is
it how much of the population is this
red group let's just like make up some
numbers suppose this is like you know
let's call that 19% cuz 19 is my
favorite number let's call this like 41%
let's this is a small one that's called
at 7% this is like well percent once
that day about it's all awake this F
will be 19 plus 41 16 6779 so that
leaves 21 so my skies have been off okay
but just imagine here are five groups
what I might like to do is to say okay
in my sample however large it would be I
want to make sure that 19 percent of my
sample is from the red group and I want
to make sure 41 percent of my sample is
from the blue group and so on and so on
and so on
now these subgroups here okay they have
a really important me they called strata
it's just a Latin word for layers which
is why we're drawn like this okay so
because we're doing is we're taking
proportions from each of the strata to
try and get this equal representation we
call this record is a stratified random
sample fancy word okay it just leaves
it's always and I want to make sure I
get some of each of the layers I want to
gets less of the school lands and more
of the big waves does that make sense
so this is just suppose in my population
my target population this is everyone
okay there are some people in this group
suppose these could be NPCs for example
okay it's like 90% of the population are
going to be you know Latino very 41% the
poppers are gonna be Caucasian and then
7% don't ever be Asian or whatever it is
okay I want to make sure my sample has
the same proportions as the target
population so what would I do
let's come back to school for a minute
what would I do here to insure out of my
nine I get a sample that is equal
representation what would I do
yeah very good I'd say well I've picked
it odd number which is a bit awkward but
suppose we get four in five that's close
enough okay maybe I'll say I can look
I'll say randomly number the boys and
then pick four of them then randomly
number the girls and speak five of them
okay
then I'm going to avoid this kind of
problem I'm not going to by chance get
all girls and no boys like we almost
have in this class okay I'm going to get
something reasonably close to equal
does that make sense